so Brady Changi Tang the uh famous
Chinese mathematician well he's done it
again it's about 10 years ago we did a
video on the twin Prime conjecture
which was solved well not solved
entirely but sort of a big progress was
made by this unknown Chinese
mathematician it came out of literally
nowhere and made huge progress so just
to recap what that was about so the twin
Prime conjecture that's where you know
we've known for many many years since
the days of Euclid that uh there are an
infinite number of primes what the twin
Prime conjecture says is that there are
an infinite number of primes that differ
by just two so if p is a prime then P
plus 2 would also be a prime and there
should be an infinite number of those
guys now itang didn't prove that result
but what he did prove was that there are
an infinite number of primes that differ
by 70 million
so that's still a you know a finite
number and then since that remarkable
proof mathematicians have got together
they've collaborated in something called
the polymath project and they've managed
to bring that gap down to I think
246. so now we know that there are an
infinite number of primes that differ by
246. this is all down to air Changi Tang
but now he's done it again in another uh
big result you know possible big result
in analytic number Theory
and it has to do with something called
seagull zeros Siegel zero Siegel zeros
or Landau seagull zeros what are these
to really understand what this is we
have to go back to the Riemann
hypothesis which I know you've done
videos about before so just to quickly
uh remember what that's all about so you
know you think about this the the uh the
so-called zeta function which we've
we've seen before in lots of
varyingly controversial context this is
where you take the sum over n greater
than equal to one of n to the minus s so
this would be like you know if you'd
have one to the minus S Plus 2 to the
minus s plus three to the minus s and so
on including all the integers so this is
known as the rieman zeta function you
know for example and we know that if we
set this number s to minus one then we
have the sum of all the integers or all
the positive integers and we know what
that gives us without any controversy it
gives us minus a 12. the answer to this
sum is remarkably minus a 12.
but this is this is a very interesting
um function in analytic number Theory we
know that for if this s if it's real
part is bigger than one then this this
uh sum will converge and we can extend
the definition of this function to the
whole to all complex numbers using this
sort of mathematical process called
analytic continuation so this thing can
be defined in principle for all complex
numbers what's really interesting about
this guy is is where does it vanish
there's an interesting result that you
can link this two prime numbers this is
a famous result due to Euler that if I
go through through all the prime numbers
like this if I take products of prime
numbers like this to the minus one
divided and one minus three for the
minus s to the minus one the one minus
five to the minus s so five minus one
and so when I take all these products so
I take these combinations of prime
numbers so these are all prime number
entries sitting in here and I can carry
on all the way up to Infinity this is
also related to the to the zeta function
this is a result due to Euler so I think
you've discussed this before right that
this so knowing about this function
tells you about prime numbers and how
prime numbers are distributed one of the
interesting things to ask is where does
this function vanish we can draw the
complex plane okay so this is the real
part of s this is the imaginary part of
s if I draw the line where s equals this
is the this is one here zero here so
this is the line where the real part of
s is one this is the line where the real
part of s is zero and we know the the
function converges in this region here
to the right of one I can continue the
results to the whole complex plane
I know it turns out that you can show
quite easily that there are zeros at
minus two
minus four and basically all these sort
of negative even values this is where
there's we know these are called the
trivial zeros of the zeta function
they're not so interesting what's
interesting What's called the
non-trivial zeros and it's known that
those non-trivial zeros will lie in this
critical strip between zero and one the
famous Riemann hypothesis says not only
did they lie in this strip but they
actually lie on one particular line
where the real part of this complex
number s is a half so the claim of the
Riemann hypothesis is that all the
non-trivial zeros of this very important
function which is related to prime
numbers will lie on this line here so
they'll all be here here wherever they
are that's the claim of the Riemann
hypothesis so now one can generalize
this to have something generalized this
idea to something called the generalized
Riemann hypothesis it's very similar so
what we do is we just generalize this
function a little bit so what we do is
instead of considering these sums Over N
to the minus s we consider a related set
of sums so it's still very similar so
you still have your n to the minus s's
like we had before but now we weight it
with this waiting Factor basically it's
very similar to what we have before but
they're just slightly weighted each
contribution slightly weighted by this
number Chi so if you want to write it
out in full it would be ID of one one's
in a minus S Plus k d of 2 2 to the
minus s and so on right the these are
called the dirichelay L functions and
these guys
these factors well these are the sort of
new ingredient that we have now they are
various properties of course these
functions that sit out front here they
basically you know they they take
integers n to some complex number okay
and that's what they are they're just
some function that does that they have
lots of properties that you can discuss
but we don't want to go into all the
details
the most important one is what this D
represents and that's called the modulus
and that's just the statement that
whatever this function is it's periodic
so if I take some integer and then I add
D to it then it doesn't change the value
of what this function does so if I for
example if I evaluate this function at n
equals 1
then I get the same value at D plus one
you see what I mean so it's just it's
periodic it just repeats okay so
examples of this thing right so if the
modulus is if D equals one if the
modulus is one then this turns out has
to be the trivial What's called the
trivial character and that means that
it's just one it's always one one
everywhere gives us back this if the
modulus is two then you then the the
only thing you can have is is What's
called the principal character
and what that is that's either that
flips between uh zero and one and think
it's um it's one for odd numbers and
zero for even numbers and so it just has
that sort of waiting if you go to higher
D higher modulus you get just more
complicated stuff it's just a
mathematical construction the details
don't really matter
the point is this is kind of like a
generalization of disease to function
okay
the claim is of the generalized Riemann
hypothesis is that for these guys again
the non-trivial zeros lie on this
critical line that's the generalized
readable hypothesis
so we've gone round about now we have to
get back to Siegel zeros
Siegel zeros is a counter example to
that
so single zeros are zeros which don't
lie on this line in fact they're zeros
that potentially lie very close to this
line where the real part is one
particular they'll lie sort of around
here so they're real zeros which lie
very close to one basically that's the
idea of a single zero if a seagull zero
exists
then you can prove all sorts of
wonderful things so there's there's
loads of sort of proofs you can do in
analytics number theory that rely on the
existence of a sequel to zero if it
exists you can prove this if it doesn't
exist well no you maybe can't can't
prove it here's an example there's
something called the heath Brown theorem
it says the following one of the
following has to be true
there are no single zeros
or
the twin prying conjecture is true
so one of those has to be true okay they
can't both be false so so in other words
if you if you find a single zero
if you can show that it does exist then
that means the twin Prime projector has
to be true you see so so you can see
that these the existence or absence of
these signals there is really important
for proofs in analytic number Theory
okay so so this is what itang is
thinking about
okay now the the precise statement of
where the seagull zero lies is the
following
it should lie on the real line
very close to one
how close well that's part of the
theorem it should lie within a small
distance here
which should go like C which is just
some number
over log d
so remember what these things are see
it's just a number it's an absolute
number it it doesn't matter what it is
it's just a number that doesn't depend
on d d is this sort of periodic property
the modulus of these of these characters
here that's the claim of the sequel zero
if it exists it should lie in this
little tiny region close to one okay and
that width of that is C over log D okay
right
if it exists of course
the generalized Riemann hypothesis is
false as well that's another thing right
because you know if that's the if that
zero is there then that's that's off the
line that's off the critical line right
so it's another important result
what did Italian prove he didn't prove
the absence of these zeros he didn't
prove that he proved so what you would
like to show is that these zeros don't
exist in any of this region here
eliminate that area you want to
eliminate that area that's that's the
that's the thing you're striving for he
didn't do that
he managed to show that zeros didn't
exist in a much thinner region
okay and the reason that he was looking
at
it had this width
okay so he was able to prove so this is
a much thinner region much closer to one
and he was able to show that there were
no zeros in something of that width
okay now you might wonder where the
hell's that 2024 come from right
um well he was he did this by proving a
related result which included the number
2022 which was of course this year right
so it's a bit of an arbitrary choice
he himself says he can bring this number
down to order a few hundred whether he
can bring it down to the one that you
need to really capture this statement
about single zeros and where they are
and the thing that's then going to feed
into all these other proofs
well I talked to some number theories
here at Nottingham and they were saying
well that's probably going to need some
new input to do that uh but it's still a
big breakthrough it's still it's still
sort of you know a real Advance if
correct compared to what's gone before
he's narrowed the search field a bit yes
so basically he's been able to show that
if you go really really close to one in
this region here there are no single
zeros but to get capture the full
statement you need to prove it in this
slightly larger region okay and as we
bring this number down that region is
going to get bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger until you
capture the whole lot
and then once you've got that then all
these factors that go into other proofs
and this that and the other will really
kick in even this result can have an
impact on some sort of other
mathematical proofs do you want there to
be no SQL zeros no I'd like to be one
definitely because if this proves the
remain hypothesis right or the
generalized treatment hypothesis that's
bad news if we disprove the room yes new
stuff is fun ready new stuff you don't
expect so most by the way most
mathematicians would say that there's
probably no single zero it's generally
so the proof's that it's it's considered
what's called uh illusory that's what
that's the terminology they use so so
you can prove this if if there is a
single zero but it's an illusory proof
because chances are there isn't a single
zero isn't there a lot of mathematics
that will just crumble if we disprove
the Roman hypothesis like it'll be like
oh lots of things we thought were true
aren't there lots of proofs that sort of
say this is assuming the Riemann
hypothesis is true there are yes and but
then this then goes deep into proof
Theory I mean you can have um statements
which are which are based on the
correctness of their even hypothesis and
statements which are based on the sort
of incorrectness of the Riemann
hypothesis actually and then you just
take into different branches of
mathematics actually and this is a
really interesting notion
um you know people look at which is like
um
trying to unpick the theories of
mathematics and trying to understand
um what proves rely on what assumptions
and therefore and then if you break
those what does which branch of
mathematics does that take you in so you
know it's not very Loosely you might say
well a lot of I say I only have real
numbers you know what can I prove well
then you can already prove so much but
then you can say well I can extend the
my axioms I can stand the rules of the
games include complex numbers improve
and other stuff and and then there's
this whole game that you can play with
with mathematics so you're absolutely
right it's a just be fun right if there
is one oh there's my little single zero
how cool would that be have to name it
after you could become the Padilla zero
well if I found it I don't think there's
a chance of me find in it it's in there
somewhere right
but but you know so this of course has
has implications in in physics as well
at least the distribution of prime
numbers so so the zeros of the zeta
function you know they've been connected
to um
energy levels of heavy nuclei so there's
a connection there right so
understanding the zeros of the zeta
function can maybe tell you something
about the energy levels heavy nuclear
sort of distributed you know it's really
quite profound potentially in terms of
this this result this latest result that
is proven
um the jury is still out amongst the
mathematical world as it should be
um Mass Has This brilliant uh sort of
philosophy that what they do is is it
you know they really the peer review
process is incredible in mathematics
they take a very long time to unpick
each other's work and it's a really
serious process so that's going to take
at least a year probably you know people
like Terry tower for example have
already commented on the on the on the
manuscript saying that the
um a certain sort of inconsistent
equation equation referencing and sort
of just things in the paper that are
making it difficult to sort of follow
the proof and check it so um you know it
just needs a time to just to sort of
tighten it up tidy it up and then say it
off you go guys they'll check it see if
you if you agree and actually it may be
that they don't agree I mean this has
happened before right it may be that
they spot a small error but they're not
normally happens it's such a healthy
culture what will happen then is rather
than everyone going oh it's wrong
they'll probably you know try to work
together with the with the person
reviewing the paper and actually try and
fix it and actually you haven't this
happened in the past with Famous Last
Theorem and things like that of course
so
yeah I guess the jury is still out but
it's potentially quite exciting
how do you build a brain that will solve
the universe's wildest problems
well you can start by giving it a
workout at brilliant here's a world of
courses questions and puzzles that have
been lovingly designed to make learning
an absolute pleasure look they even have
a bunch of stuff here about modular
arithmetic which was touched on by Tony
today
actually they've got loads about modular
arithmetic
I've got loads about everything really
everything's so clean and elegant
cleverly put together and really
interactive you never want to stop you
always want to see what the next
question is going to be at least I do so
don't be a fooled be a dollop get 20 off
your brilliant premium subscription by
going to brilliant.org number file that
Link's also in the description you can
also give brilliant as a gift to the
future or maybe current genius in your
life
see all the details on the website
[Music]
well I don't know about seagull zeros
but the search for Tony's book fantastic
numbers and where to find them just got
a whole lot easier because it's been
released in the US you can see both the
UK and US covers here on the screen
there'll be a link to that in the video
description